is there an actor whose work or career
you try to emulate Wow
good question Wow um I have a lot of
especially now there's a lot of actors
that I truly truly enjoy watching them
work that are scary good that I want to
emulate alright I look at I'd like to
emulate like their careers as in do like
60 to 80 movies and have a successful
career yeah but I want to be that actor
that nobody knows their name but you
know his face I'd love to be that guy
just because I don't want Fame I
wouldn't want it for nothing
I just want wow that guy works a lot
what's his name again what's his name
again that's what I would love to have
like I'll say his name call him out but
there's certain actors that you you know
you just recognize their face but you'll
never know their name because it works
so much and you feel like they're a part
of you but you just don't know who they
are that's why I'm like you don't want I
want like a beat complete mystery like
Sidney pottier said it best you know do
you want Fame or do you want success
success you know because Fame everybody
knows who you are how does it take the
mystery out when you play a role so I
was like okay that makes perfect sense
so to answer the question is there
actors there's many actors but I would
love a career like let's say Denzel
Washington or you know Anthony Mackie or
a champion one of those guys yeah I'd
love to take it dropping a dime what is
it about Fame that scares you or turns
you off just in addition to that you
can't play in a unique character because
you're talking because Fame everybody
knows who you are and about you and they
clearly want to know what's going on
outside of your works so they're always
especially in this day and age where
there's a camera everywhere
as a reality show there's Twitter
there's they know who you are now
because there's pictures you're inviting
them in you to your family in your life
to me that takes away a lot from the
character you're trying to play when
you're playing a store to role because
like hey that's the guy I just saw who
just do a full party the other day now
he's playing some serial killer in the
1600s it doesn't work for me that's why
and plus famous that's another monster
that's not for me at all so do you think
it's destructive it's so many ways but
if you're a strong person you know how
to handle yourself but that kind of Fame
I'm the one everybody everywhere you go
knows who you are that's snow no no
that's not good at all okay
do you believe a lot of what you see I
mean I don't have to name names but
there's people that are out there every
day with some shocking news do you think
it's real or you think it's
manufacturing and we're all the suckers
we're the ones I'd say I think half of
its real and half of its a lot of it's
just I need to be famous right now let
me go do something stupid because
there's some celebrities out there who
probably lost a step or two and they
still need that kind of attention so
they'll do something that's just you
know that's just not me
well thank you do you think you'd ever
turn down a role because you'd be afraid
that it might take you to that level no
I'll do anything that I I'd fall in love
with and get the opportunity to do of
course but if Fame comes with something
you do and you know what's about to
happen I know what profession I chose so
it's bittersweet I just know I would
know how to handle that I would just
stay away from like certain things like
you know reality shows and stuff like
that is my personal life is way
secretive
no thank you has anybody given you
advice on how to handle yourself with
that happen or I've had mentors I've had
mentors leading up to this point but
it's always great to have especially
someone who's been in the industry so
long advice from them on a regular basis
all I would love that but do I have it
as in now somewhat I can say somewhat I
do I have like a couple of friends that
are deep in the game that could help you
out but I don't pull that card yet if
that makes sense
yeah have they ever said to you some of
the things to watch out for oh yeah or
or to continue to do yeah they did tell
you the bait the main thing is is just
to continue to attack do whatever you
can like from plays to student films to
even infomercials just to keep it the
skill going it's just that in this town
you know it's it's tougher for certain
individuals to go to certain markets
because they already have their image of
what's supposed to be there so it's good
to have someone to tell you you know the
ins and outs a little bit yeah did they
tell you don't some ones stay away from
this little stuff like you know drugs
nonsense people who are gonna scam you
see here that's the thing that's scary
because everybody's here for something
but you just don't know what they here
for so just learn to the detectable
nonsense I guess
you